foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar clinical
and operational aspects of measuring
hemoglobin e1c bicapillary
electrophoresis I'm Susie Valdez of
labroots and I will be your moderator
for today's event today's educational
web seminar is presented by labroots and
brought to you by sebia to learn more
visit them at cba.com now we encourage
you to participate today by submitting
any questions you might have during this
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
Send we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation you may also submit any
technical issues here as well if you
have any trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation I'd now like to welcome our
speaker Dr David Grenache Chief
scientific officer at TriCore reference
Laboratories Dr ganache welcome you may
now begin your presentation
well thank you for the introduction it's
my pleasure to be here with you guys
today uh to talk about uh some clinical
and operational aspects of measuring
hemoglobin A1c bicapillary
electrophoresis
uh per my disclosures I do acknowledge
that I have received speaker honorariums
from Sabia
and these are the learning objectives
for my presentation today
all right so you just so you can put my
whole um presentation in context I want
to tell you just a little bit about
where I work at TriCore reference
Laboratories where an independent
non-profit laboratory system located in
the state of New Mexico in the
southwestern part of the United States
and we'd like to consider ourselves New
Mexico's laboratory because we have our
operation really across the entire State
we operate as a hub and spoke model so
we have one centralized core laboratory
where I am in the City of Albuquerque
but Tricor also operates Hospital
Laboratories in 18
um 18 hospitals and cancer centers
around the state and we do serve as the
laboratory for the three largest Health
Care Systems in the state of New Mexico
we also have several Branch Labs these
are smaller Laboratories that are
located in
Urgent Care Centers and we have 29
patient care centers where people can go
and have a phlebotomy performed our menu
consists of just about 3 000 different
tests and we perform approximately one
million tests a month we are cap 15189
accredited so all the other usual things
that you think about a laboratory but we
are a system lab right so uh we uh
anything that any tests that are not
done in the hospital or Cancer Center
Laboratories those those Laboratories do
tests that are required for immediate
patient care and anything that's not
urgent is brought here to the core the
core Laboratory
so let's get started
um I'm going to start with the case
report about a 36 year old woman um from
Sicilian descent so she has a history of
obesity and hypertension and she
complains of being tired and she has
frequent urination at night
uh her fasting plasma glucose is 124.
um you'll probably recognize that a
diagnosis of diabetes mellitus requires
one of the diagnostic criteria is a
fasting plasma glucose of 126 or higher
so she's pretty close to that
um her hemoglobin A1c is performed by an
immunoassay was normal at 5.3 percent
and her provider assured her that she
did not have diabetes but four months
later her fasting plasma glucose is 142
so it has crossed that diagnostic
threshold
a two hour 75 gram oral glucose
tolerance test was performed and the two
hour result was 220 which also exceeded
the cutoff of of less than 200 to
establish a diagnosis of diabetes and
her A1C performed at that time was by
high performance liquid chromatography
uh with
16.7 so obviously extremely elevated and
notably a presumptive hemoglobin variant
was noted in her in her test result she
was eventually diagnosed with diabetes
but also with a hemoglobin s beta plus
thalassemia
so that's clearly a little bit unusual
right we have these two very discrepit
hemoglobin A1c results performed over a
four-month period uh we'll talk more
about why that occurred later on
uh so let's just do a quick review of um
some basic things like hemoglobin uh in
most individuals hemoglobins can be
categorized into three groups there's
hemoglobin a which represents about 97
percent of the hemoglobins and then some
minor hemoglobins hemoglobin F very low
0.5 for often zero percent and
hemoglobin A2 about 2.5 percent uh there
are some hemoglobin there are there are
some hemoglobin variants that are
important and have those off to the side
and we'll talk about those a little bit
more later on
um but I really want to point out here
that the majority of hemoglobin a is not
glycated right about 96 97 of hemoglobin
a is not like 90 excuse me 94 is not
glycated
um but approximately six percent of
hemoglobin a uh which refer to as
hemoglobin A1 is glycated and of those
glycated hemoglobins a hemoglobin A1A
and hemoglobin a1b make up about one
percent of that glycated hemoglobin and
hemoglobin A1c the star of today's show
makes up about five percent of
hemoglobin A1
um and those glycated hemoglobins uh uh
include different subspecies so for
example uh if we look under the umbrella
of hemoglobin a1s the glycated
hemoglobins hemoglobin A1 A1 is glycated
with a fruit molecule of fructose 1 6
diphosphate
hemoglobin a1a2 is glycated with glucose
6-phosphate
hemoglobin a1b has pyruvate attached to
it and hemoglobin A1c again the star of
our show today uh has a molecule of
glucose attached to it so and as you're
very well aware uh hemoglobin A1c
reflects the average blood glucose
concentration over the previous two to
three months which is the average uh
lifespan of a normal red blood cell
so it's hemoglobin A1c is currently the
most widely used index of average
glycemia for the routine monitoring and
prevention of long-term complications of
diabetes and further the American
Diabetes Association and the World
Health Organization also endorse the use
of hemoglobin A1C for the diagnosis of
diabetes mellitus
because of those clinical uses it's
really important that we be aware of the
factors that are known to interfere with
hemoglobin A1c tests and these
interferences can be caused by specific
analytical methods that are used to
measure hemoglobin A1c
as well as through biological variables
so I mentioned that there are some
abnormal hemoglobins and I want to go
into a brief explanation of the four
most common ones
because that these do contribute to some
of that anal they do contribute to that
Analytical in the biological sources of
variation that we have to understand
when we're selecting and Inter selecting
an A1C method and then interpreting
results
um because not all patients have just
hemoglobin a
so these hemoglobinopathies or these
hemoglobin variants uh arise from
mutated forms of the genes that encode
either the alpha globin or the beta
globin chains of hemoglobin and that
results in some amino acid changes that
create these these abnormal hemoglobin
variants
and while there are literally hundreds
of hemoglobin variants that have been
identified the four most common ones
that are mutations in the beta globin
chain are shown here so starting in the
upper left hand corner we have
hemoglobin s right hemoglobin s is
created one of one of when the amino
acid valine is substituted for glutamic
acid
at the sixth amino acid position of the
beta globin change
a chain and individuals can be
heterozygous they can have a phenotype
of hemoglobin a s these individuals are
typically asymptomatic their red blood
cells have a normal lifespan but
individuals who are homozygous who have
inherited two copies of the hemoglobin
of the mutation that causes hemoglobinus
um have sickle cell anemia and they have
a decreased RBC lifespan very short
about 15 days
right underneath that in the lower left
hand side is hemoglobin C here
hemoglobin C is produced when there's a
lysine amino acid substituted for the
glutamic acid at the sixth amino acid
position again individuals who are um a
heterozygous are asymptomatic normal RBC
lifespan homozygous individuals who have
hemoglobin C disease have a very mild
hemolytic anemia with a slightly
decreased RBC lifespan
the upper right we have hemoglobin D we
have a substitution of glutamine for
glutamic acid but at the 121st amino
acid position of the beta globin chain
and there are several variants of
hemoglobin D but the most uh common one
is uh D Punjab
heterozygous individuals uh like the
other variants are asymptomatic with a
normal uh RBC lifespan
uh homozygous individuals do have a mild
hemolytic anemia with a decreased RBC
lifespan
and then hemoglobin e is a glutamic acid
substituted for lysine at the 26th
position uh there is a slight reduction
in these individuals hemoglobin each
show a slight reduction in the synthesis
of beta globin
heterozygous individuals are
asymptomatic the normal lifespan of rbcs
heterozy homozygous individuals have a
mild microcytic anemia and because of
the decreased synthesis of the beta
globin chain they have uh indicators
that suggest that that that
give them a phenotype of beta
thalassemia minor
so that's the last hemoglobinopathy I
want to talk about is beta thalassemias
so these mutations don't result in an
amino acid substitution of the beta of
the beta globin chain these mutations
decrease the synthesis of the uh of the
uh
the globin chains so we could have uh
because hemoglobin because there's a
decreased synthesis of the beta globin
chain these individuals have increased
synthesis of the Delta chain right so if
we have hemoglobin A2 is composed of two
alpha chains and two Delta chains and
they have increased synthesis of
uh the gamma chains which and so
individuals who have hemoglobin F uh
have a structure of hemoglobin that's
two alpha two alpha chains and two gamma
chains
individuals who have beta thalassemia
can be classified into either those uh
two different groups those that are
transfusion independent uh these have we
often refer to this as beta thalassemia
minor because they have one gene that's
mutated they have a mild microcytic
anemia elevations usually of hemoglobin
A2 and then beta thalassemia major where
you have both genes affected these
individuals have a microcytic anemia and
they are often transfusion dependent
um on the The Matrix on the right what
I'm showing you here are the clinical
manifestations of both homozygous
individuals and compound heterozygous
individuals for the uh for the
hemoglobin variants in beta thalassemia
because as that case report uh
demonstrated at the start we had an
individual who had hemoglobin s beta
thalassemia and so you can see in The
Matrix when individuals have these um
either homozygous conditions or compound
heterozygous conditions they often have
some sort of decreased lifespan and of
their red blood cells and uh their uh
they have anemia
so with that is background I want to
talk about the different methods the
analytical methods that are available uh
to measure hemoglobin A1c in clinical
laboratories
um at a recent so to give you an idea of
of the predominance of the different
methods I'm going to start with this
slide so when we look at recent cap
survey data we can see that the the most
commonly used method to measure
hemoglobin A1c is immunoassay 51 of
Laboratories that are reporting uh
utilize an immunoassay method that's
followed by hplc followed by an
enzymatic method followed by boronate
Affinity chromatography and Then
followed lastly by capillary
electrophoresis so I want to talk a
little bit about each one of these
methods and some of their pros and cons
and we'll start with immunoassays so
most immunoassays are turbinometric
inhibition tests and shown in the panel
a in the imagine a situation where
there's no hemoglobin A1c present
um at all so there's no blood present in
the sample at all
um there are some there are reagent
polyheptines that these polyheptines are
just synthetic molecules that contain
multiple A1C epitopes and they react
with antibodies to hemoglobin A1c that
are conjugated to a micro particle and
this combination of these polyheptines
and these antibodies bound to a micro
particle cause the microparticles to
form an insoluble complex that
precipitates and results in significant
light scattering
now imagine this situation where uh
blood sample is introduced and
hemoglobin A1c is present
the hemoglobin A1c in the sample also
reacts with those
anti-hemoglobin A1C antibodies uh
forming complexes that reduce that
they bind up those antibodies so it
prevents the polyheptines from binding
and there's a reduction in light
scattering and what's actually measured
is the rate of reaction that reaction
rate is measured turbotometrically and
that the so that such that the light
scattering the amount of light
scattering is inversely proportional to
the amount of A1C in the sample
um I think it's important to point out
that early immunoassays so the first
generation of A1C immunoassays they
tended to overestimate hemoglobin A1c uh
in individuals who uh had either
hemoglobin s or hemoglobin C traits and
that was because the antibodies in the
first generation test spanned the the
epitopes that they detected those the
epitopes that those antibodies detected
spanned amino acid number six which as
you'll remember is the amino acid that
is substituted in hemoglobin s and
hemoglobin C
however current uh immunoassays so the
ones that are in use today do yield
accurate results because the antibodies
now span amino acids one to four so they
have it avoids that um that that amino
acid number six
however even though those immunoassays
that are in use today span amino acids
one to four they do yield accurate
results
but they will also produce a result a
hemoglobin A1c result in individuals who
don't even have hemoglobin a so for
example individuals with hemoglobin s
disease that are homozygous for
hemoglobin as
um they'll get an A1C result and while
that alone is misleading right because
it's hard you have a hemoglobin A1c
result in a person who doesn't even have
hemoglobin a so that result alone is
misleading
um but also individuals with hemoglobin
uh with sickle cell disease uh their red
blood cells have a decreased lifespan
and if red blood cells have a decreased
lifespan then hemoglobin A1c results
will will be clinically misleading
because it'll be lower than they uh they
they would be in individuals with
shortened RBC lifespans
and it's also important to note
that an immunoassay will not be able to
detect uh if an individual has a
hemoglobin variant or not and why that
is important I'll discuss a little bit
later
the next essay I want to talk about is
the enzymatic assays and enzymatic
assays utilize a protease to produce
small peptides and amino acids from the
beta globin chain including the
n-terminal glycated valenes from the
hemoglobin A1c molecule that's shown up
at the top on the left hand side of that
drawing
uh enzymatic removal of the sugar
residue from that glycated valine
produces hydrogen peroxide and the
formation of hydrogen peroxide is
measured using a colorimetric assay
and like immunoassays enzymatic assays
fail to detect if a hemoglobin variant
is present and so it will produce
clinically misleading results in
patients who don't have hemoglobin a
and boronate Affinity chromatography a
lysate of red blood cells is added to a
column that contains buronic acid and in
an alkaline pH the glycated proteins are
bound to the column while the
non-glycated proteins flow through the
column
after that an acid buffer is added to
the column to release the bound glycated
proteins
beauty of this method is that it
produces just two hemoglobin Peaks a
non-glycated hemoglobin Peak and a
glycated hemoglobin Peak making the
result interpretation relatively simple
however these methods
measure total glycated hemoglobin not
just hemoglobin A1c and so the result
has to be mathematically corrected to
yield an a hemoglobin A1c equivalent
result
um boronate Affinity chromatography
methods are unaffected by the presence
of hemoglobin variants but they can
produce a clinically misleading results
because again they don't detect
hemoglobin variants and
um again because of shortened RBC
lifespan and homozygous individuals the
A1C result can be clinically misleading
the second most common method for
measuring hemoglobin A1c is hplc
that's an ion exchange high performance
liquid chromatography that separates the
hemoglobin species based upon charge
differences
so positively charged hemoglobin
molecules move more slowly than the
negatively charged molecules through the
column because the column is packed with
a negatively charged resin
so hemoglobin A1c will e-loop first
because it's more negatively charged
than hemoglobin than non-glycated
hemoglobin a
other hemoglobin species and some
hemoglobin variants can be resolved uh
by hplc and presumptively identified
because they appear as additional peaks
in the chromatogram
however although hplc can often identify
the presence of some hemoglobin variants
it's important to note that different
hplc methods even from the same vendor
have different resolving power right so
the ability to separate those hemoglobin
Peaks from each other is uh really can
be really important uh so that we it
doesn't so that the method doesn't
produce an inaccurate result
uh and lastly the last method I want to
talk about which I'll go into a little
bit more detail uh later on is capillary
electrophoresis so Capital capillary
electrophoresis is a method that
combines elements of classical Zone
electrophoresis with liquid
chromatography and while it's commonly
used in Laboratories for serum protein
electrophoresis testing it is less
commonly used for A1C testing with only
about two percent of Laboratories
utilizing that method as I showed you
earlier
so capillary electrophoresis separates
hemoglobin species based upon their
Electro electrophoretic mobility and
Electro osmotic flow in an alkaline
buffer
after the sample is introduced uh at at
the anodic end of the capillary a high
voltage protein separation is performed
and direct detection of the hemoglobins
is made at the uh at the Cathedral end
of the capillary uh direct detection
right through the capillary using a
detector at a wavelength of light at 415
nanometers now like hplc methods
capillary electrophoresis can detect the
presence of hemoglobin variants but the
advantage of capillary electrophoresis
is that it has extremely high resolution
and so we can completely separate
hemoglobin variants from each from the
other hemoglobins and that results in a
method that does not cause or doesn't or
or is not susceptible to interference
from
um from other hemoglobin variants
and we can completely separate
hemoglobin a from hemoglobin A1c
so I want to tell you now about the
hemoglobin the TriCore experience uh
with hemoglobin A1c testing and a little
bit about our journey and where we've
landed
um so just give your idea of the testing
volume so that we have
um because I have this graph right so we
we perform about 28 000 hemoglobin A1c
tests every month here in our core
laboratory and the testing is performed
in our hematology Laboratory
and that was done that's done because so
often we get
um a single lavender top tube for both
the CBC and a hemoglobin A1C test so
it's just it's a little bit more
efficient for us to have both to have
A1C testing done in our hematology
Laboratory
um if we go back a few decades to 1998
that's when uh TriCore started and
um we began testing hemoglobin A1c using
an hplc system and we use that system
for several years
in 2012 we had to change our uh our
platform because our our instruments
were aging
um and uh we were on an hplc system for
several years after that but in 2019 we
had to do an uh an RFP to consider
replacement options because our uh our
current instruments were aging and the
columns had to be replaced frequently
frequently uh we had a lot of service
calls it was it was just time to replace
them and rather than just automatically
consider a replacement method that was
hplc we decided to look at all of our
options so we looked at these four we
looked at two hplc methods that's the
total so G8 and the biorad D100 we also
looked at considered the boronate
Affinity chromatography method the
Trinity Premiere method and we
considered capillary electrophoresis we
involved key operators so our our key
technologists in the laboratory in the
hematology laboratory in the process and
they helped lead us in the decision
making
so here's a little bit about uh what we
believe to be the pros and cons of the
methods that we evaluated so for the
toso G8 ion exchange hplc
um
an advantage is its broad measuring
range right can measure hemoglobin A1c
from a low of four percent to a high of
18 but we actually saw that there were
several
um disadvantages uh it has a relatively
slow slow throughput at only 35 samples
per hour
um and at our volume of testing that's
not fast enough
uh the evaluation of the chromatogram
you have to look at it because there can
be variants uh it has to be done on a
little paper roll that comes off of the
instrument so the chromatograms the
chromatic grams are on a paper
um we personally our processed was when
we identified individuals that have the
had a hemoglobin variant we would create
an index card and keep it in a file
folder um and that and that we we kept
track of those individuals because when
they came back we wanted to make sure we
were producing accurate A1C results to
the best of our ability
um there were reports of interferences
from common hemoglobin variants with
this method
um and at that time that we were doing
our evaluation we could not report a
hemoglobin A1c result that was greater
than nine percent in the presence of a
common hemoglobin variant that has
subsequently been resolved by the
manufacturer with a software update but
when we were going through this process
that was still a quite a burden for us
to handle because we had to not report
those results and send those samples out
to our referral Laboratory
um we couldn't report an A1C result if
there was a hemoglobin F concentration
greater than 10 percent and hemoglobin
A1c is reported as a percent of total
hemoglobin rather than uh uh a percent
of
hemoglobin A1c plus hemoglobin a
um the other method we evaluated was the
boronate Affinity chromatography method
that also had a very broad measuring
range the nice thing about it is the
ease of interpretation because you only
get those two peaks glycated hemoglobin
and non-glycated hemoglobin and an
advantage was that there's no
interference from common hemoglobin
variants
but again we thought the throughput was
a little bit too slow for us at 45
samples per hour and
um it measures remember measures total
glycated hemoglobin and A1C has to be
mathematically derived and although
there's no interference from hemoglobin
variants the the presence or absence of
a hemoglobin variant cannot be
identified by a boronate Affinity
chromatography method
so we thought that that we considered
that to be a disadvantage
the other hplc method we looked at
um had a much higher throughput than the
other one at about 80 samples an hour so
that would meet our needs at a very high
a very broad
measuring range and there was no
interference from common hemoglobin
variants but it reports hemoglobin A1c
as a percent of the total hemoglobin
again not as a percent of the hemoglobin
A1c plus hemoglobin a
and then lastly uh we evaluated
capillary electrophoresis from Sabia it
has a high throughput uh high enough for
us at 70 samples per hour a broad
measuring range no interference from
common hemoglobin variants hemoglobin
A1c is reported as is recommended as a
percent of hemoglobin A1c plus
hemoglobin a and what really sealed the
deal for us was the superior resolution
of the of hemoglobins from capillary
electrophoresis
um the the disadvantage is that we have
to use sabia's QC products we can't use
a third-party vendor for their QC
so
um after we considered all of our
options we settled on uh the capillary
electrophoresis method again because it
has Superior resolution
it can detect hemoglobin variants very
easily because of that Superior
resolution there's also no interference
with the hemoglobin A1c measurement it's
very automated it has automated mixing
of the whole blood sample and the it has
it has high throughput it has high
enough it has certainly has high enough
throughput for our needs
and I'm showing the slide just to give
you an example of the the resolution
right so here are four different
individuals that are heterozygous for
either hemoglobin s c d or E uh and you
can see that in each of these cases
hemoglobin A1c which is this smaller
Peak out here is uh completely resolved
uh from the um the other hemoglobins
include including hemoglobin a so you
can still easily determine the
hemoglobin A1c concentration even in the
presence of these abnormal hemoglobins
um this is our current workflow
um now that we have switched to a
capillary electrophoresis method so
samples are received here at the core
lab and into our sample Management
Department uh they're received and
they're accessioned uh we have a robotic
sorter that sorts the samples for the
hematology lab to a specific location uh
for hematology in on the robotics order
um and then lab assistants bring the
hemoglobin A1c and CPC samples uh to our
CBC instrumentation we use a sysmex
platform for cbcs and it's on an
automation line
um and then that the end of that
automation line right here is a sorter
um on the sysmex line that will then
sort samples that need an A1C into a A1c
rack and then that is located right next
to the uh the capillary instruments that
are shown there in that bottom figure
that bottom picture uh and they have to
they do have to be manually loaded onto
the instrument
um for the analysis to occur
um but once they're on the instrument
the workflow is automated the the vast
majority of A1C results will Auto verify
um what holds uh any sample with a
hemoglobin variant uh is not Auto
verified it is held in the Lis and uh
for manual review
um the way we report results is probably
very similar to how your laboratory
reports them uh we are they these
instruments are interfaced and so the
results flow right across uh through our
uh into our middleware data Innovations
There are rules that are based upon that
are based in the DI middleware that um
are are triggered based upon results and
I'll talk about some of those
momentarily uh and then the results in
those comments that are rule triggered
um are sent into our Lis which is
Sunquest and then Sunquest sends that
data those results on to our clients EMR
um the elements that we report are
obviously the hemoglobin A1c result we
also report estimated average glucose as
it is calculated from hemoglobin A1c
result and then any comments that are
appropriate that again that are that are
automatically added based upon the rules
we built in our middleware those are
also added to the result as well when
appropriate
so I'm going to go through the different
comments that we do have
um so here's the here's essentially the
the rules and the comment that gets
appended and then I'm also showing you
the frequency with which we see these
scenarios uh in that far on the far
right hand side and that's base this
frequencies are calculated from just
under a hundred thousand A1C results
that have been performed um in the past
uh
I guess a couple few months
so scenario of an A1C that's less than
four percent that's below the measuring
range of the capillary instrument
um we report a result that is less than
four percent the estimated average
glucose is reported as just less than 68
and then that's the comment that we
attached it says with that that we're
detecting hemoglobin A1c but we can't
measure it accurately uh and then we
comment that extremely low values can be
associated with conditions that alter
the lifespan of the red blood cells and
then we suggest that serum fructosamine
can be considered as an alternative
method to evaluate glycemic control in
such individuals
and that's very rare that happens we see
that about 0.05 percent of the time
uh the opposite end of that Spectrum if
the hemoglobin A1c exceeds the measuring
range we report a greater than result
estimated average glucose is reported as
greater than 427 and we do not add any
comment again pretty low frequency with
which we see such extremely high A1C
results
um if we if if a inter if a interfering
hemoglobin variant is detected right
because there's hundreds of hemoglobin
variants
um it's possible that some of them
could interfere with the hemoglobin A1c
measurement in capillary electrophoresis
we haven't encountered any yet
um we would not report an A1C result uh
we therefore we don't report an
estimated average glucose and we would
comment that uh we detected a hemoglobin
variant that interferes with the
measurement and then we suggest
performing hemoglobin electrophoresis if
clinically indicated and then again
serum fructose amine could be considered
as an alternate method we have not yet
encountered this situation in the uh
not two years that we've been using
capillary electrophoresis
um we do detect non-interfering
hemoglobin variants like those common
ones s d c and e
um
we do report because we can we can
report a hemoglobin A1c result and we
know it's accurate
we know that it's not interfered with
from the method we're using we do report
estimated average glucose and we say
that we are detecting a hemoglobin
variant that does not interfere with
hemoglobin A1c measurements and we
suggest performing hemoglobin
electrophoresis that clinically
indicated and we see this uh relatively
commonly about a half a percent of the
of the samples that we test so
um you know one out of 200 samples
um if hemoglobin f is less than 24 then
we can still report a hemoglobin A1c
result we report an average glucose and
we say the hemoglobin f is present at a
concentration that doesn't interfere
suggests performing hemoglobin
electrophoresis if indicated and again
something that's relatively infrequently
encountered
uh even less frequently encountered are
samples with a very high hemoglobin F
concentration greater than 23 we cannot
report A1C so we do not report average
glucose and we say exactly that that
hemoglobin f is present at a
concentration that can cause a negative
interference with hemoglobin A1c and we
suggest performing hemoglobin
electrophoresis if needed and serum
fructosamine as an alternative method
for glycemic evaluating glycemic control
um if no hemoglobin a is present so
individuals with say sickle cell disease
um then we don't report an A1C result
because there's no hemoglobin a
and we tell them that there's no
hemoglobin a detected because there is a
homozygous or hemozygous hemoglobin
variant uh and we remind them that in
the absence of any hemoglobin a there is
no hemoglobin A1c to be reported and
then suggest hemoglobin electrophoresis
needed and serum fructose amine to
evaluate glycemic control
um let's see and then oh yeah uh if
hemoglobin A2 is between three and seven
point eight percent uh we do report A1C
we do report average glucose but we
we're prompting them in our comment that
there is an elevated concentration of A2
that could indicate a beta thalassemia
syndrome we suggest performing
hemoglobin electrophoresis if needed and
we comment that hemoglobin A1c could be
decreased due to a shortened lifespan of
the red blood cells and serum fructose
amine could be considered as an
alternative and that happens fairly
frequently about 0.5 percent again about
one out of every
um uh 200 samples
so while things like well numbers like
0.5 percent of samples seems really low
right individuals have hemoglobin
variant or perhaps beta thalassemia well
0.5 sounds low
um based upon our volumes it's a pretty
substantial number of absolute number of
samples that we encounter
um uh uh here at tri-core so what I'm
showing you here is that same volume
graph day week month year but now I'm
I've adjusted it for the absolute number
of samples that actually have a
hemoglobin variant that we have detected
um and at you know 2 000 patients a year
where we're detecting a hemoglobin
variant
um I think is is is a value-add and and
an important piece of clinical
information that may not have been
recognized
um and it's another reason why
I'm really pleased with our decision to
go to capillary electrophoresis because
of our ability to report uh hemoglobin
A1c result in such patients uh and the
the fact that we can
so that's all I have for you today
um just as a summary analytical methods
and biological factors into can
interfere with hemoglobin A1c
measurements or the interpretation of
the result
um notably though 75 of Laboratories uh
utilize A1C methods that cannot detect a
hemoglobin variant and that and or that
produce an A1C result in the absence of
any hemoglobin a at all
uh detecting hemoglobin variants while
not the intended purpose of an A1C test
is important to avoid reporting
misleading A1C results
um hplc and capillary electrophoresis
A1C methods can detect hemoglobin
variants but its capillary
electrophoresis that really provides
that Superior resolution of the
hemoglobin species and minimizes uh
interferences
uh and with that I'd be happy to take
any questions thank you for your time
thank you Dr ganache for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live q a portion of this
webinar and if you have any questions
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on that ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen and we'll
answer as many questions as we have time
for so let's take a look we already have
some great questions coming in
our first question what ultimately LED
you Dr ganache to capillary
electrophoresis for HBA 1C testing
uh yeah
um well I as I explained in the
presentation you know we did that RFP
and we involved our uh our technical
leaders in the laboratory
uh and I think what ultimately uh sealed
the deal for us was the superior
resolution that uh capillary
electrophoresis method provides us and
its ability to detect
um hemoglobin variants
thank you so much now when people hear
the term electrophoresis they don't
think about operational efficiency how
does a reference lab the size of
tri-core manage their hba1c testing
volume using capillary electrophoresis
yeah so you're right I mean the the
terms electrophoresis doesn't really
evoke a high throughput methods right
but technologies have changed quite a
bit over the years and uh the capillary
electrophoresis method that we now use
is pretty high throughput I mean it
Rivals that of
hplc methods uh probably not doesn't
rival that of immunoassay though
um for us uh you know the instrument
that we use has 12 capillaries in and we
have two instruments so we have the
ability to do 24 uh hemoglobin A1c
assessments simultaneously uh and given
our volumes which are fairly High uh
we're able to uh to keep up with that
with that workload
um so again for us it was that
combination of uh I think what what we
consider to be a superior analytical
method uh coupled with the throughput
that we needed to meet our client our
volume that we have
thank you so much now Dr ganache in the
case of homozygous variant why not
indicate to the clinician that the RBC
lifespan is likely affected and no
measure of hba1c
um or glycated HP is useful
yeah that that's a that the person who
asked that is very observant
um and I recognize that as a uh
something we needed to start doing
um as I prepared this presentation uh we
we have a similar comment when there's
elevated hemoglobin A2 which is
suggestive of a beta thalassemia but we
neglected uh to add that to our comment
when there is a hemoglobin a homozygous
variant so that will be remedied I think
the the questioner for pointing that out
thank you so much and I want to thank
our audience for these great questions
that are coming in Dr ganache do you
send out the hgbf or have analyzer to
have an allyzer to run that
um well I'm not quite sure I understand
the question uh you know when hemoglobin
f is detected in uh uh in a hemoglobin
A1c measurement we don't we don't report
that
um we as long as it's less than the um
the threshold if a hemoglobin f is less
than
um I think 23 then we can still report
the A1C uh if it's greater than that
then we usually will in we indicate that
a hemoglobin electrophoresis might be
warranted and if the clinician orders
hemoglobin electrophoresis then and
hemoglobin f is present then that's
something that we do report
quantitatively
thank you so much now how do amino acid
methods compare with separation methods
in regards to samples with elevated hbf
uh oh gosh that's a good question
um I'm I'm not I'm not very familiar
with the effective hemoglobin F on
immunoassays for A1C probably they're
okay
um I I'm not speaking with any
experience because I've actually never
I've never used a hemoglobin A1c method
but that that was an immunoassay based
method so I'm not as familiar but I I I
hypothesize that there isn't um that
there isn't interference from hemoglobin
F but I'm sure there are uh members in
the audience who who know far better
than me and if you do know the answer
I'd encourage you to put it in the
question
uh the question box
thank you so much now our next audience
member says hi I have a question for
follow-up of patients for hba1c where HB
variants are detected on Ce will the
patients become their own reference
range for diabetic follow-up how do you
communicate this info to the clinician
could you could you read that again sure
and it's number 13 Dr ganache
um I have a question from follow-up
patient for for hba1c where HB variants
are detected on Ce well the patients
become their own reference range for
diabetic follow-up and how do you
communicate this info to the clinician
um
no we they uh
if we detected hemoglobin variant by
capillary electrophoresis
um all we say is that there is a
hemoglobin variant that does or does not
interfere with the A1C measurement
um the test is the essay the method's
not approved to identify the hemoglobin
variant to the clinician so we say that
there is a variant and that hemoglobin
electrophoresis could be considered if
it's clinically indicated
um
but
in the vast majority of hemoglobin
variants by
excuse me the vast majority of
hemoglobin A1c Assessments in patients
with the hemoglobin variant uh assuming
it's heterozygous are are accurate so uh
there's no I I don't I don't there's no
need for each patient to become their
own reference range
um serial testing of course is important
in patients with diabetes to monitor
glycemic control and in that regard you
know longitudinal data so historical
data
is important and that's the
responsibility of the clinician to
interpret the most recent hemoglobin A1c
result in light of the patient's
historical results
thank you so much now do you use your
capillary analyzers for other testing or
just ha1c
yeah so we have two dedicated uh
capillary electrophoresis instruments
that are in the hematology lab that are
only used for hemoglobin A1c assessments
we also have the same instruments in our
Immunology lab
where we perform uh serum protein
electrophoresis hemoglobin
electrophoresis immunotyping
Etc so we still we still use the same
capillary electrophoresis technology but
on um different instruments that we use
for hemoglobin A1c those are just used
for A1C
it looks like we have time for a couple
of more questions this knocks neck
audience member says this thank you so
much for this wonderful presentation
what is the effect of sample hemolysis
in case of CE report interpretation
can you tell me what number that is 20.
we have such great questions coming in
from our audience
well if the sample was is
I understand
um as long unless the sample is entirely
hemalized
um which is very unlikely uh there
shouldn't be an effect on the A1C result
uh we need we do want intact red blood
cells which are subsequently hemolized
right as part of the procedure to
release the hemoglobin from those red
blood cells but if there is some
hemolysis already in the sample
should be it should not be impactful
thank you so much we have time for one
more question
Dr ganache to follow up immunity assay
methods commonly stimulate that A1C
should not be reported if the patient
has elevated hbf over seven percent or
thereabouts however cannot detect for
the presence of hbf how could this
negatively impact the results
thank you for the the clarification uh
so remember earlier I said I'm really
not familiar with the impact of
hemoglobin F on uh A1C method
measurements by immunoassay
um so this uh if this individual has
shared with us that
um they commonly say that you should not
report an A1C result if hemoglobin f is
over seven percent
um that's a challenge for you know in an
immunoassay method you're not going to
know the hemoglobin F percentage uh so
it's kind of nice that the immunoassay
methods tell you that that's a problem
but
um the laboratory is not going to have
any awareness of what the actual
abundance of hemoglobin f is because
they're not going to be testing or
looking for it
um
so that's that's a conundrum right I
think that's another reason why I'm
pretty pleased that we're not using an
immunoassay method for A1C
Dr ganache I want to thank you for your
presentation would you like to provide
any closing remarks to our audience
before we go
uh no thanks for the attention and your
interest in the presentation
um uh we have our a our our journey with
the hemoglobin A1c testing has been uh
pretty steady for many years until we
made this switch uh but the laboratory
is very happy with the the instruments
and the method that we've chosen uh and
I'm really uh I have a lot of confidence
in the results that we report
um and I really am pleased that we're
able to identify patients who have
hemoglobin variants uh yet still in
nearly all cases we've encountered uh
still able to report an accurate A1C
with the caveat that in you know
homozygous patients there is a decrease
in um well there's no hemoglobin a but
there's the risk of uh uh decreased
um uh red blood cell life span and
therefore an effect on the A1C result so
those are my final comments
well I want to thank you again for your
time and your presentation and for your
important research and I'd also like to
thank lab roots and our sponsor CBF for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go I also want to thank our
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by our speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration and this webcast
can be viewed on demand so elaborates
will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with the colleagues who
missed today's live event until next
time take care everyone
bye bye thank you